le micro de notre journaliste stéphane
liégeois les bordelais se sont exprimés
sur le racisme dans la police et les
violences policières et goûter il ya des
policier raciste
ces règles sont gentils il faut punir
les policiers racistes comme n'importe
quel raciste et il faut pas faire
d'amalgamé par ces débris et qui font
vraiment bien leur boulot qui aiment
leur boulot elle est très bien cette
police impeccable depuis qu'on est passé
de des gardiens de la paix a forces de
l'ordre je trouve qu'ils sont ils s'en
servent un petit peu trop là en ce
moment malheureusement il est plutôt
négatif va de manière générale je vois
que la police française elle est là pour
faire respecter les lois et pour faire
régner l'ordre dans la société
on ne peut pas dit que la police
française les assistent m'ont un peu on
peut comprendre qu'ils aient des agents
de la police qui sont racistes ça c'est
ça se comprend en fait qu'on me dit de
la police c'est bien gentil moi parce
que là c'est la personne en tant que
policier c'est pas la police en général
c'est la personne que j'ai derrière moi
la police n'avait pas raciste qui sont
les personnes qui a derrière ce qu'ils
préfèrent des généralités pour moi ça
sert à rien il ya des violences
policières depuis quelques années et
qu'elle a du mal à reconnaître et à
s'autodiscipliner dans ses rangs voilà
mais c'est pas forcément de sa faute
c'est la faute
à l'état qui donne pas forcément d
instruction ni des formations adéquates
j'ai un avis totalement neutre je pense
qu'il ya beaucoup de policiers qui font
bien leur travail et qui a quelques
brebis galeuses qui comme dans tous les
corps de métier va fond des choses qui
sont un peu moins bien voilà c'est bien
c'est bien que les gens se mobilisent
pour dénoncer des situations
discrimination qui n'ont que trop duré